o índice ism em seus territórios
quem conhece quem não conhece todo mundo
conhece a não sei se isso é bom ou ruim
a mas porque eu estou perguntando isso
porque na semana retrasada foi a são
paulo e ministrar um treinamento para os
executivos de uma multinacional na hora
do almoço a gente estava saboreando uma
deliciosa salada um quiche quando
começou um papo sobre o programa de tv e
eu não sei a troco de quê
eu falei dos habitantes rogério um dos
gestores virou pra mim e falou andré eu
assisti muito teletubbies quando era
pequeno
imediatamente o 112 pensamentos na minha
cabeça
o primeiro pra vocês todos que conhecem
o programa deve imaginar qual foi um
tremendo alívio pelo programa não ter
deixado as sequelas em quem assistiu e o
segundo pensamento foi caramba
a geração que assistiu teletubbies já
está no mercado de trabalho e já em
cargo de liderança na direita e rogério
falei nossa a vida realmente passa muito
rápido o tempo voa eu estou muito velha
aí suzana uma outra gestor é muito
simpática inclusive parecidíssima
planilha da cantora virou pra mim falar
andréia que isso você tá muito
conservada os céus
toda vez que alguém fala que eu estou
conservada eu me sinto o próprio picles
que é isso
tudo bem não foi ali naquele momento que
eu me dei conta de que eu já sou de
algumas gerações anteriores
tá na verdade um dos primeiros indícios
de quando a gente está se integrando de
geração envelhecendo se vocês pedirem é
que com isso as palavras pessoas usam
para nos elogiar mudam
atualmente você passa toda a vida
ouvindo que você é linda maravilhosa e
gostosa e de repente do nada
as pessoas começam a dizer que você está
bem bem gente na boa
desde quando bem elogio e esse está
também esse tempo do verbo sabe com toda
essa transitoriedade ali lá muito
confortável mas enfim vamos voltar ao
nosso almoço porque aquela história dos
teletubbies a coisa rendeu inclusive
porque éramos ali uma autêntica a sopa
de letrinhas
tinham pessoas da geração baby boomer x
y e já comentando sobre a geração z está
a caminho do mercado de trabalho ea
geração alfa pra gente se situar eu vou
falar mais ou menos a classificação das
gerações
eu digo mais ou menos porque os autores
divergem bastante sobre as datas e claro
eu adotei aquela que lhe coloca na
geração se né
nós né e não na geração baby boomers que
são os nascidos logo após o final da
segunda guerra mundial até o ano de 1960
quem aqui é baby boomers deve entregar
ninguém não é só a gente tem idéia de
quantos de que geração baby boomer pode
notar mão de ficar com vergonha não todo
mundo tem uma geração para carregar no
coração tá aí depois vem a geração x
nascidos de 61 81 é do gosto né
aí depois da geração y ou milênios aí
levantava a mão antes de pedir sentiu
como é que é
tá só porque são 82 a 2000 a gente sabe
tudo bem
depois vem a geração z de 2001 a 2010
tem alguém que de 2010 em diante geração
alfa ou nativos digitais como também são
chamados
não tem ninguém que seria muito pequeno
mas enfim voltando então lá o nosso
almoço ea tal guerra de gerações como
essa guerra se dá cada um defende a sua
letrinha e mete o pau nas outras e as
queixas não variam muito
todos os treinamentos e palestras por aí
afora invariavelmente discurso escutas
mesmas queixas e nem experiências
campeãs são velocidade comprometimento
os mais jovens até os mais velhos muito
lentos e muito comprometidos com o
trabalho com carga com a empresa
já os mais velhos acham os mais jovens
muito acelerados e muito pouco
comprometidos com o trabalho tarde com a
empresa inclusive uma das frases mais
escuta os mais velhos falar em relação
aos mais jovens é que eles mal entram na
empresa e já querem ser presidente
pois é eu vou falar agora uma coisa para
você
muito simples e no entanto muito muito
importante
gerações diferentes são diferentes
nem melhores nem piores são diferentes
em relação a essas diferenças eu quero
ressaltar três pontos que considero
essenciais está o primeiro deles é que
essa classificação deve ser vista como
referência não como rotulação quando a
gente rotula a gente cria uma série de
imagens e idéias pré-concebidas que
fazem com que a gente não vejo o outro
como ele de fato é
então quanto lá não tem nada a ver eu
conheço muita gente de uma determinada
geração que tem todas as características
de outra
o segundo ponto é que a gente deve ver
as gerações dentro de um contexto porque
é de 46 para cá no mundo mudou muito
gente mudou de 60 70 80 90 pra cá tem
desde 1990 para os 2000 anos né
e aí eu pra ilustrar melhor essa
passagem do tempo com todas essas
mudanças eu queria te trazer para vocês
um trabalho muito sentido científico pra
caramba e
pra isso me dediquei por meses e meses a
fio a trazer hoje aqui
esse estudo mudou bastante né gente
pois é tanta que nem todos nós mudamos
tanto quanto nosso amigo michael jackson
aliás uma outra coisa interessante é que
quando a gente está sem envelhecer sendo
as pessoas adoram chega pra gente dizer
assim
nossa você está muito bem ou bem aí de
novo você não mudou nada bom para o
nosso amigo michael jackson ninguém
poderia falar isso né
enfim e com certeza um dos grandes
impulsionadores de toda essa avalanche
de mudanças foi a o avanço tecnológico
na minha área por exemplo nos últimos
dez anos descobriu se mais sobre o
funcionamento do cérebro humano do que
tudo o que se sabia anteriormente
eu não sei vocês mas eu até hoje não sei
a diferença entre menta e hortelã e já
tem gente inventando carro que anda sem
motorista gente eu acho fantástico
o que a gente está vivendo agora é o que
nós chamamos de temporariedade
permanente
tudo é temporário nada é permanente e as
novas gerações né em peso
ela está muito habituado às peças com
esse mundo acelerado com esse ritmo
frenético com essa inconstância das
coisas em permanência das coisas
para grande parte de vocês e da geração
como todos as gerações mais jovens a
única coisa que se perde permanente na
vida são suas tatuagens
pois é já para as gerações anteriores
como a minha por exemplo geração x das
coisas é um pouquinho mais devagar
tudo bem um pouquinho mais um pouquinho
mas olha só também se tem que dar um
desconto pra gente porque só o tempo que
a gente perdeu abrindo os malditos
plásticos de cd
lendo o manual e consultando dicionário
enciclopédico vocês não têm noção gente
foi muita coisa e o nesse meio tempo aí
as coisas evoluíram de uma tal maneira
que a comunicação por exemplo
deu assim saltos imensos é eu moro no
rio e minha tia que até pôr em algum
lugar meus tios sempre moraram aqui
niterói
quando eu era pequena queria telefonar
para ela eles não bastava pegar o
telefone e ligar direto não a gente
tinha que pedir auxílio de telefonista
eu lembro até hoje por favor niterói 20
266 juro nas nossas casas também os
telefones
normalmente a gente tinha um telefone
fixo seja lembra que o telefone fixo que
listassem espetadinha tomadas amanhã é
que ele pois é esse mesmo o que sem fio
nem pensar fixo-fixo mesmo e normalmente
ficava num lugar assim estratégico da
casa todo mundo ouvir a nossa conversa
uma delícia lá em casa por exemplo como
em muitas outras estava no corredor
privacidade
esquece a 0 quem diria que há alguns
anos depois grande parte da comunicação
seja feita com os polegares inclusive se
você usar o indicador para teclar o
celular pode ter certeza que você é um
picles
não tenha dúvida disso e o fato é que
todas as projeções que foram feitas não
deram conta de tantas mudanças que nós
teríamos em tão pouco tempo inclusive né
usando novamente o nosso amigo michael
jackson como metáfora tem história
interessante para contar nos anos 80 uma
revista americana
pedi um artista famoso que fizesse a
projeção de como seria michael jackson
no ano de 2000 e foi assim que o
projetou
errou feio né 0 eo terceiro e último
ponto que eu quero destacar sobre as
diferenças das gerações é que a gente
precisa também considerar as imensas
mudanças que ocorreram tanto no ambiente
familiar quanto profissional
nas famílias as famílias normalmente
eram maiores
as mães habitualmente não trabalhava
fora todo mundo fazer as refeições à
mesa e as pessoas se relacionavam
interagiu mais até porque nós não
tínhamos o nosso famoso objeto de
distração e massa nem tv a cabo e isso
fazia com que a gente tivesse que
refinar nossas relações interpessoais
para que as coisas acontecerem pra gente
se entender vai morar por exemplo como
eu um apartamento em que éramos nela
queridas sete pessoas todas saindo de
manhã praticamente na mesma hora para
trabalhar ou estudar até no banheiro na
casa sujeito a gente tinha que se
entender as coisas tinham que fluí
tinham que acontecer hoje de uma maneira
geral as famílias reduziram muito para
grande parte dos casais dois filhos está
de bom tamanho e outra parcela
significativa optou pelo filho único
vamos lá em casa né filhinha linda ela é
e isso está trazendo assim um pacto um
reflexo muito grande nas relações
interpessoais não só ali no núcleo
familiar com o núcleo social e
profissional
até porque irmãos educam mutuamente né
eles educam mutuamente
claro que nem sempre com muito carinho
nem afecto e nem paciência mas eles
educam e no ambiente profissional também
as coisas mudarem mensalmente uma das
primeiras coisas que me chama atenção é
que até muito pouco tempo atrás nós
tínhamos o horário fixo para entrar e
para sair do trabalho e quando a gente
saía do trabalho a gente só voltava
trabalhando no dia seguinte
agora a gente fica conectado 24 horas
por dia
quando a gente também ganhava um cargo
de chefia né
a gente grava uma sala especial só pra
gente
normalmente um banheiro exclusivo aí
quanto melhor o cargo melhor e maior a
fala eo banheiro e não raro com ele
direito a elevador privativo
já faz tempo que as empresas derrubaram
todos esses muros nessas salas especiais
e até a aas bahia estavam tão em moda já
caíram em desgraça
inclusive algumas empresas uma delas
aquela de são paulo na história dos
talentosos as pessoas sequer em mesas
exclusivas ou seja elas chegam para
trabalhar e senta na que tiver dando
sopa
então essas são algumas das inúmeras
milhares milhões de mudanças de que
ocorreram ao longo desses anos e que tem
um impacto muito grande na vida de todos
nós
eu queria falar muito mais consolidado
18 minutos né
o interessante é que eu ouço falar muito
em diversidade e ainda assim eu vejo
muita gente levantando um muro e se
isolando e fazendo críticas muito
contundentes uns aos outros e eu quero
fazer uma pergunta para você como é que
você quer ser visto no ambiente não só
profissional como social como aquela
pessoa intransigente e arrogante ou como
uma pessoa respeitosa empática acredite
as duas últimas características valem
ouro
as gerações são diferentes sim porque
viveram e vivem experiências de vida
muito diferentes e isso teve tem e
sempre terá um impacto muito grande nas
nossas vidas
é importante a gente procurar conhecer
uns aos outros
hoje com o aumento da expectativa de
vida que já está na casa dos 75 anos
aumentando cada vez mais o mundo se
tornou um imenso caldeirão com pessoas
de todas as idades e de todas as
gerações se relacionando com vivendo
isso não tem volta
é importante a gente conhecer para
compreender essa é a fórmula não tem
outra conhecer as pessoas procurar saber
suas histórias de vida suas realidades
não cabe mais uma postura de confronto
de disputa de quem é melhor ou pior
somos diferentes lembrando que o
diferente é incrível a gente precisa
conhecer mais os outros pra não do
contrário a gente vai estar levantando
muros intransponíveis uma pessoa de 20
anos não é metade de uma de 40 e não
vale metade de uma de 40 da mesma forma
que uma de 40 não é o dobro e nem vale o
dobro do que uma d20 somos diferentes
eu trouxe pra vocês uma frase
na verdade é um provérbio japonês que eu
considero precioso
todos somos mais inteligentes do que
qualquer um de nós um mundo atual clama
por pessoas de todas as idades de todas
as gerações que não constrói muros nem
geográficas nem de idiomas nem étnicos
nem religiosos nem o lógicos nem sócio
econômicos nem de gêneros e nem de
faixas etárias
o mundo clama por pessoas mais abertas a
conhecerem melhor a respeitarem os
diferentes pontos de vista e a crescerem
juntas até porque a vida é muito curta
mas ela não precisa e nem deve ser
pequena
obrigada
[Aplausos]